welcome back
we talked about we just finished talking
about confidence intervals in the
previous segment and now we'll talk
about hypothesis testing which is a
closely related idea
we want to ask a question about a
specific value of a parameter like is
that coefficient zero
and in statistics that's known as
hypothesis testing so hypothesis testing
is a test of a
of a relationship between
it's a test of a certain value of a
parameter
in particular here the hypothesis test
we'll make is that is that parameter
zero is the slope zero
so what's called the null hypothesis is
that there's no relationship between x
and y
in other words
in other words beta one
equals 0 right
that's this equivalent statement the
alternative hypothesis is that
relationship there is some relationship
between x and y in other words beta 1 is
not zero
and beta 1 could be
positive or negative
okay
so mathematically this corresponds to
beta 1 being 0 is the null hypothesis
beta 1 not equals 0.
okay
so that's that's often the question you
want to add that's usually the first
question you want to ask about the
predictors
so to test the null hypothesis
we
form what's called a t statistic we
we we take the estimated slope divided
by the standard error
this will approximately have a t
distribution with n minus two degrees of
freedom under assuming that the null
hypothesis is true
now what is a t distribution you have to
worry too much about that it's basically
you look this up in a table or
nowadays you look you know in software
or compute it for you it's basically a
normal random variable
for except for small numbers of
samples and it's a little bit different
in any case you you ask the computer to
compute
the
p-value based on this statistic
okay
p-value is the probability of getting a
value of t
at least as large as you got
in absolute value
okay
so for the advertising data using again
just tv
um
here's here are the results here the
slope and intercept of that line we saw
the least squares line
standard errors
here are the t statistics that's just
the coefficient divided by the standard
error the one we care most about is for
tv the intercept isn't really very
interesting that's telling us what
happens
what's the the sales when
the the tv is zero tv budget is zero
but the one i care most about here is
this guy
so this this is this is measuring the
effect of
tv advertising on sales
and the t-statistic is huge okay it's
much
it turns out the in order to be
to have a
p-value of below 0.05
which is quite significant you need a
t-statistic of about 2. we're at 17. so
it's very very significant so the
p-value is very very small
so how do we interpret this it says
the chance of seeing this data
under the assumption that the of the
null hypothesis that there's no
effect of tv advertising on sales
is less than 10 to the minus four so
it's very unlikely to have seen this
data it's possible but very unlikely
under the assumption that tv advertising
has no effect
our conclusion therefore is that tv
advertising has an effect
on sales as we
would hope
okay
so
we've seen how to fit a model with a
single predictor
and how to assess the slope of that
predictor both in terms of confidence
intervals
and hypothesis test now i did want to
add one thing
that's important so we've seen the
hypothesis test and before that we saw
confidence intervals there's actually a
one-to-one correspondence in other words
they're doing equivalent things
to be more precise
if the hypothesis test fails if not if
we reject the null hypothesis and
conclude that beta1 is not zero
as we did for tv advertising
correspondingly the confidence interval
constructed for that data
for the parameter will not contain zero
conversely if the hypothesis test does
not reject
so we cannot conclude that
t tv advertising has an effect its slope
may be zero the confidence interval for
that parameter will contain zero so the
really the confidence interval is also
doing hypothesis testing for you
but it's also telling you how big the
effect is
so it's always good to compute
confidence intervals as well as do a
hypothesis test
so for example here we see
the interval doesn't contain zero
furthermore we see that a lower limit on
the effect of
tv advertising is .042
which we can interpret as these are in
thousand dollar units that we we're
going to affect sales by 1 000 times
oh so for for every 1000 change in
tv advertising the we'll get a
corresponding change in in sales so this
tells us not only is the effect zero or
not but how big is the effect likely to
be
okay
so where are we now let's see
so
we talked about how to assess the slope
of a individual predictor
how about the the overall fit of the
model the accuracy of the model
well what we can do here is we'll take
the
the residual sum of squares remember
this is the quantity that we minimized
in the first place to get
the best estimates of the intercept and
slope the least squares estimates
so we'll take what's called the mean
squared residual and take the square
root this is the average square
deviation that we have we achieve
using the best the least fitting line
where this is the residual sum of
squares
and
we compute what's called the r squared
or the fr the fraction of variance
explained and here it is
it's the total sum of squares
minus the the zero sum of squares over
the total sum of squares so what is this
conceptually well if we didn't fit a
model at all if we just if we forget
about tv advertising just use the mean
of the of sales as the prediction that's
sort of the simplest prediction you can
imagine
this would be our
our error right this is here's our
prediction here's the true
sales
so this is the no model error
and now the residual sum of squares of
the fitted model is rss
this is how much it's going to be lower
than this guy right it's going to be
lower because we could always achieve
this guy just by choosing a slope of
zero so
since we've done least squares we've
optimized over the parameters we know
that rss will be less than tss but this
quantity measures how much do we reduce
the total sum of squares relative to
itself
okay and here it can written this way or
this way so this is the fraction of
variance explained
and
it can be shown algebraically this is
actually equivalent
to
the squared correlation between x and y
right so this is simple correlation
between the predictor and the outcome
it kind of makes sense right the heart
the higher the correlation
the more that we
will explain the variance and there's
actually an exact algebraic relationship
that
the squared correlation is equal to this
fraction of variance explained
so what do we get for our data
the r squared is 0.61
here it is so in other words
we've using tv sales we've
the the budget excuse me tv budget we
reduce the variance
in advertising in
sales
by 61
so that's quite a that's a very strong
predictor the f statistic we'll talk
about in a few minutes it's also a
measure of
how well the overall model is doing
so
you know this is quite impressive you
know in in
in business and some kind of physical
sciences we see r squares like this in
medicine
we don't tend to see r squares you might
see r squared of five percent you might
get excited
so always have one has to remember the
um the domain to sort of get to have a
judge of how good an r squared is but
this is an impressive r squared which
you see sometimes in business and
finance applications
so that completes our discussion of
regression with a single predictor in
the next section we'll move on to the
harder problem where we have multiple
predictors and we do a multiple
regression